this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem okay look I could not afford to
get a 15th Doctor Cosplay in time for
this review maybe in time for for his
first season proper and the Sonic
Screwdriver that he has is not available
yet um this one does seem to have the
same sounds as that does though just
going by ear sounded like the same thing
look just roll with
[Music]
it
the church on Ruby Road the new
Christmas special for Doctor Who the
first proper outing for shoy goa's 15th
doctor the numbering is is is a disaster
it has been for a while but it's just
getting worse but yes shy gatwa as the
doctor we get to meet uh Ruby Sunday who
is the new companion and we just get a
rolicking Christmas
Adventure I should probably caveat it
with the fact that I tend to not love
the Christmas specials as much as a lot
of other people do uh especially a lot
of the UK fans I tend to be a little bit
harsher on them
I they can be good I like I'll actually
be having a ranking of the specials not
just the Christmas specials but all the
Doctor Who specials of the modern era at
least um next month but
overall a lot of them they're
just they're light and fluffy and I I
get why it's Christmas we're not trying
to be really heavy you know it's fun
family entertainment people have opened
their presents and now they just kicking
back and relaxing with the family
watching something fun like I get it I
get why a lot of episodes are the way
they are
I just don't like them as much as a lot
of the other stuff that doctor who does
when doctor who feels frivolous to
me ah I don't know it doesn't completely
lose my interest but I'm not going to be
as invested and this is leaning on the
frivolous side of things now does that
make it bad no absolutely not I'd
actually call it one of the good
frivolous uh stories but that does also
mean that I feel like I don't have that
much to talk about because the story
is the story is kind of not the point uh
the point is the Aesthetics the feel the
uh sense of getting to know the doctor
and the companion but just the rolicking
adventure atmosphere that's the
point which it
does what does that leave me to talk
about though well there are a few things
and I will get to uh Millie Gibson and
shudy gwa proper in a little bit let me
just talk a little bit broadly about
this the whole thing with the goblins
like this is nitpicky and I know this is
nitpicky but it bothers me that they're
called goblins when their entire Mo fits
a lot better with
Gremlins uh if you don't sort of know
the the I'm not going to say that this
is accurate like fairy lore but like
generally speaking Gremlins are the
thing that mess with the electricity and
you know just cause bad things to happen
Gremlins in their Machinery that's the
same Gremlins brought down our planes in
the big one that's Gremlins that's not
goblins and I suspect that they just
called them goblins just to have shiwa
do that do you know why they call them
goblins cuz they like to go you up I
don't think it was worth it at least not
for someone with my particular set of
brain wirings because I'm just like but
the they're they're behaving like
Gremlins though again this does not
actually matter I don't want to go off
on it but like it did bug me a little
bit um but overall I like the general
notion of they lean into and they they
sort of it's not that they're empowered
by coincidence but it's like coincidence
and luck is how they get a foothold in
our universe that's kind of interesting
and that General notion and like as uh
coincidences accumulate it kind of
powers them up a little bit more I kind
of like that the
song the song's fine like honestly I
probably would have appreciated it more
if they hadn't released it in advance
and so I could have been caught off
guard like by like oh my gosh they're
singing how great is that but instead
like I know it's coming so I I feel like
for me at least the most value I ever
would have gotten out of the song would
been the unexpectedness of it and they
ruined that as a song unto itself and as
a thing like it's fine gatwa and Gibson
got some good voices good on them cool
uh whoever they got to do the the main
singing she was good but it's it's it's
fine knowing it was there sucked a lot
of the fun out of it for me and again I
understand that it's probably more of a
me problem than actually a problem uh
with the episode
proper so there isn't too much else to
talk about with the the Goblins or the
story you know the the whole thing with
the the newscaster who I guess is
actually an actual newscaster like I'm
sure that has meaning for folks in the
UK has none to me she could have just
been an actress for all I
knew I don't know who deina Mcall is
so she performed well enough she didn't
come across like somebody who didn't
know how to act so I guess props to her
for that she wants to transition into
acting I think she'll do okay um the
last moment was odd never seen a tardis
before like addressing it directly to
the
camera I feel like there's definitely
going to be fans who are going to go off
the deep end speculating about that I
think it was just meant as a cheeky
direct to camera hey it's Christmas
going out on a laugh kind of moment but
it's it's weird and it's built up to in
excess if that's all it is if that's not
all it is
then okay here's what I'll say I'm not
going to do speculation I'm bad at it
but uh what I will say is that if this
is
Meaningful uh you kind of undercut it by
having it presented this frivolously hey
it's Vera from the editing phase and
apparently Russell T D has said some
things indicating that yeah this is
meant to be something and it's going to
be a quote unquote Slow Burn who is this
flood come back and find out I was going
to just tack on something here but
honestly I'm probably going to have to
go off on this for a little bit so I'm
going to throw up an additional video in
the break room as soon as that's
available I will link to it both in the
description and a little card on this
video but for right now just know I'm
going to have to talk about this
separately okay back to the thing uh so
before I get into the actual
performances my thought on the
characters of uh Ruby and the doctor uh
the other thing I guess I'll address is
I'm
hoping that the uh a lot of the supposed
mystery around
Ruby is not going to be a continuing
thing
like I'm not sure that I'm going to say
that this episode sets it up like ooh
who are her parents cuz it's not like
leaning heavily on the idea that that
stuff is important it's not like pulling
a uh um the force awakens thing where
it's like let's put all this emphasis on
like oh waiting for she's waiting for
her parents and they're mysterious and
oh there's visions and O there's things
you don't know it's just more it it
feels more like it actually is just an
aspect of her
character yeah so Russell confirmed that
this is going to be a whole thing too
I'll address it in that breakroom video
as well that having been said
mechanically all the pieces are there
for this to turn into some bigger
mystery around Ruby in particular and
that that's going to inherently make me
nervous
because well it's going to remind me of
just a mash up of two things one being
Rose Tyler with uh the daddy issues and
absent parent thing and then also claraa
uh when you make the companion a mystery
unto themselves that didn't work out
great last time it was done granted that
was Moffet this is RTD different
showrunners I get it but like it's going
to set off slight alarm bills that
having been said again to re-emphasize I
don't think this episode actually puts
that much emphasis on the idea of we
will pick this up later but they
definitely could and I'm not thrilled at
the notion that they will that's a wait
and see
thing let's talk about our actual leads
shoy gotwa as the doctor I like him I
like him a lot
so I can tell you the exact moment where
I was like okay this is definitely
working it's when they're on the goblin
ship and Ruby's trying to kick the door
down and he's fiddling with the knots
and well if you gave me a hun I am
learning the vocabulary of R beautiful
beautiful that is a first of all it's a
fun line and it was also A Great Notion
the idea that like the way the knots are
tied it's effectively this version of
like wire Ing and electricity running
through it I just kind of like that as a
notion is it a bit bommy Yeah a bit I
don't care I like it but the way he
delivered that specific line there's
this sense that you get from
him there's this joy in Discovery
there's this thrill at things he hasn't
encountered before and that is something
that the doctor does sometimes have
doesn't always but but it's not an
uncommon doctor trait but he captures it
really really well and it is a trait I
like when the doctor has it but also
something that has made very evident
with the stuff that goes on later
particularly when he is saving uh Ruby
uh spoilers by the way uh I am going to
talk about the whole thing if you didn't
guess that already watch it already if
you haven't saves Ruby as a baby that
whole thing he he sold the fact that he
was he was tense about this and he was
really trying and he did it because he
cared does he care cuz he is personally
invested he knows her personally well no
not really not yet but he cares cuz
someone's in trouble and I think selling
both of
those is a good mix
because sometimes the doctor can
seem
resigned to uh bad things
happening he at least right now feels a
lot more like like even if he thinks
it's not going to work he's going to
freaking try
regardless and I like that so that
combined with sort of the joy of
Discovery and like o this is all new
it's balanced really well because he
could easily get into like sort of a
distractable area where he's missing the
human cost of well human alien you know
the the life of people cost thing of
what's going on because he's focused on
you know ooh this is new and exciting
for me no no what do we do or frankly
some doctors just don't sell the being
personally invested in what's going on
as well as he does already I say
personally like again not like he knows
Ruby all that well but he you get the
sense that he he actually cares even
just his little interaction with the
with the cop how would you know she'll
say yes cuz the sales start and choose
it and you just couldn't wait and that
is why she loves you there's this
twinkle in his eye that isn't just I'm
clever it's I'm clever and uh I'm going
to give you a little something that'll
help
you it's really nice I really like the
feel I'm getting off him so far uh as
for Ruby solid start at present we don't
have a ton about her outside of the fact
that she is an orphan uh and was adopted
by her foster mother like most of what I
got about I got off of Ruby was based
off of how she interacted with other
people you know the way that she
interacts with her mother with her
grandmother and with the doctor and heck
with her friends you know like getting
in the cab and and uh like when they
were singing I like that she plays
keyboard but that's the kind of detail I
wish there had been more of because to
make a comparison to say uh Rose Noble
in uh the the specials especially the
starbeast the the fact that and I know
they gave like a in Universe reason for
why she does this or at least why they
take the shape that they do but the fact
that she is Crafty and makes these
little plushies to sell online that felt
like it kind of told me a lot about her
that was a real characterizing thing
that was beyond just the personality
that was a character trait that was
something she was passionate about and
the closest thing I get with that with
Ruby right now is that she plays
keyboard uh and a band with a transwoman
as the lead singer which is cool I kind
of hope we see her friends again not
just for Trans representation though yes
also for Trans representation but also
just because I want to get more of a
sense of what she cares about because
she spends most of this you know caring
about what happens to lulabel um you
know and just trying to uh find her
parents but like wanting to know her
genetics that's not really much of a
trait uh character trait to go by
like good luck finding a character who
is an orphan character who doesn't know
where they come from where that is not
an aspect of what's going on so it
doesn't feel like it adds a lot now I've
kind of I've kind of been criticizing
the lack of characterizing traits to her
I don't want to knock the performance
and I don't want to knock the
performance chemistry that she has with
the other people around her because she
has
great performance chemistry cuz she's
great talking to her mother she's great
wonderful interacting with cherry her
grandmother that's fantastic she's got a
good rapport with the doctor I like the
way they bounce off of each other so far
it's all good stuff it's just a matter
of right
now
again I know was a different showrunner
but like I'm going to compare to other
things the show has done right now I'm a
little bit nervous about getting that's
it's a few more clar Vibes because uh
Jenna Coleman always had amazing
performance chemistry well more so with
Capaldi than Smith but she always had
good performance chemistry to some
degree with whoever she was working with
but claraa especially in her first
series was brutally
underaredsky
yet I think that it's the first outing
we're not going to get everything
especially in something that's meant to
be light and cheery the way that this
very clearly is so like it's fine it is
fine that she does not have uh the
amount of depth to her character then
the amount of layers you know that we
don't find a ton about her inner life
but for the most part other than she'd
play in that band I don't know what she
would do with her time if she wasn't
caught up with the doctor I want to try
and clarify this because I think I came
across as a little muddled here we do
technically get a number of traits about
Ruby she's in the band she's someone
who's willing to go out into a club be
out at night with her friends but the
thing is I don't really know how that
fits into her life I don't know if she
would go to the club even if she wasn't
with her friends is she there more
because she just wants to be with them
and that's what they want to do is she
actually a club girl is the band thing
something she's passionate about or is
it just something that does to fill the
time that's the degree to which I want
to find out more about her and I feel
that we're currently lacking I expect
these gaps will be filled in but I think
people might get confused because there
are traits that she's given they're just
not really shown how they impact her as
a character and how she feels about them
Beyond just appearing to enjoy the
company of her friends and her family
which that's good that's just not much
yet and again that's something that you
know first series that she was in claraa
suffered from greatly a lot of people
complain about Danny pink I think the
best thing they did for claraa was put
her in that school and give her a
boyfriend give her a life outside of the
uh the adventures we were seeing her on
and actually ground her as a character a
little bit and I'm hoping we get that
with Ruby in um future episodes and
stories and Adventures cuz right now I'm
not going to say she's under
characterized yet but I'm slightly
concerned that she might end up being
that we will see regardless she does
still have very good chemistry with
Shiga which is ultimately the most
important thing that a companion needs
to have but I I do still think it's
important that they actually function as
a character even outside of the dynamic
so that's what I'm waiting on right now
other than that uh Murray Gold's back
with his
bombast it's fine I didn't I didn't talk
a ton about the music and the uh the
David Tenant specials but like I'm not
going to say that I preferred the music
that we were getting during the chimel
era in the abstract but it was a nice
break from the bombast that Murray gold
is very into providing and I'm glad
other people are excited it's back how
about we how about we go with that for a
backhanded compliment uh I'm just kind
of tired of him I don't know I seem to
be the only one with this opinion so you
know don't don't don't put too much
stock with it nobody else seems to be
where I'm at as far as that goes
and there just isn't all that much to
talk about I don't have all the all the
baggage and the weight um of the even
the first of the tenant specials you
know bringing back these characters and
there was a lot to unpack there isn't
here not yet this is our our first time
seeing this doctor this is our first
time getting to know this companion it's
a light fluffy story that doesn't have a
lot of particular at least evident to me
thematic depth to it it's a rolicking
adventure on a flying pirate ship with
goblins Gremlins goblins yeah that is
what it is and it's fun I enjoyed it
it's a good
time that's kind of all I've got though
and under other circumstances I might be
a little bit nervous that you know the
first outing for the new doctor is just
like oh it's so okay well it's fun we
going to get anything deeper than that
I'm not because it is the Christmas
special and actually I think I've even
said in the past I think we should have
it happen more often that a doctor's
first Adventure is a special so that it
can just give us a sense of them on an
adventure and then we start to dig into
the meteor stuff and their series proper
and potentially that's exactly what
we're getting I mean we'll find out when
we actually start getting uh new
episodes but it gave me a good sense of
this doctor and of this companion at
least as far as her Dynamic with the
doctor goes I want to find out more
about her as a character unto herself
um but it did the
assignment it came in light fluffy
adventurous cool
you gave me what I expected and that's
good I just don't have nearly as much to
add to the conversation as a result of
that so the church on Ruby Road what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to uh make
this my actual living and cover
everything um I was going to saying get
shirts like this except this was a
Christmas gift so maybe not but in any
case I I I can I can gift the people I
care about with silly nerdy shirts like
this with the assistance of
patreon that's not the point it's it
it's not a gift giving fund like it does
actually cover my bills although it
doesn't fully cover my bills I need the
YouTube to I'm rambling I'll stop
regardless even if you can't help me out
that way like share and subscribe they
all help me out but don't worry too much
about it what I really want you to
remember is that you are beautiful you
are valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned time for me to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin Moore
Zubin Lula goddess Ela Oliver be to rock
the thing that goes going in the anime
Ruth goes with the gazarian solitary
pictures rrick bugden geek filter Linda
Walters toku BL huian Jen a Kate 808
Becky Sparks fobi likes the poodle Robin
Powell t love Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall quite bearish Roslin Bennett
pal baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and Mira G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just just didn't just didn't I just
didn't do a thing this time but now I've
told you that I didn't do a thing so
I've made a thing about there being no
okay thanks for sticking around
bye
y